I think firstly we tried to make a
distinction between national culture and
company culture.
I mean,
when we go to China,
to India,
to Canada,
to Brazil,
to Belgium,
to Germany,
to Argentina,
of course they,
each country has different country
culture and that's great.
That's why we travel.
That's why during vacations we tried to
go to different places to experience
those difference,
different cultures.
So that is great.
On the other hand,
what we say is that she wanted to join
us.
You have to understand that we are one
company,
one culture.
And when you look at our culture,
it's so much about common sense.
It's so much about what a good athlete
would do to perform.
It's so much what a good student would
do to perform.
So it's a performance,
high performance culture that we're
trying to build here.
So I've met people,
uh,
in,
in the last 10 years we've,
we've been through five or six,
uh,
business combinations.
And during all those business
combinations,
I often ask the question,
what is different between our company
and this company?
We're merging with,
again,
not right or wrong,
but what's different?
And the only thing I could put my
fingers on was what we call the dream
people culture.
Uh,
if you have people that aspire to build
something that is out of the ordinary,
that's something that's in class that
you can be both part of and proud off.
I think that's already a very good
start.
If because of that,
you understand that as a company it can
only be as good as the quality of people
in talent,
able to attract,
retain,
deploy,
develop.
Then you have the people component,
which is very important.
You can only be as good as the kind of
people and talent you attract.
And then if you have this ownership
culture that says that this is our
business,
so therefore we should make decisions
and treated as our own business,
then you are in a much better place.
I think this is the best kept secret in
our company is a dream people culture.
Because when you look at it,
it's so consents.
It's so obvious.
Most companies would think it goes
without saying and they would take it
for granted.
Here at Anheuser Busch Inbev,
we talk about it every day because we
think that's really what we stand for,
that so much of what we are as a
company,
as a group,
and uh,
uh,
therefore it's worth talking about it
all the time.
So I'll give you an example.
If you don't buy into the dream,
if you don't mind,
to the dream that we're trying to build
something out of the ordinary,
something that's best in class,
best of your company,
the better world.
A lot of the targets that we put to our
business on a yearly basis basis don't
make sense because they are very tough
targets.
The kids feeling to try it to be best in
what you do good is not good enough.
So if you don't buy it to that dream in
the first place,
you're going to have a problem accepting
tough targets,
stretch targets.
If you buy into the concept that we're
trying to build something that's best in
class,
then of course we need to have stretch
targets because that's what we need.
Of course,
we need the best people,
not just good or average people.
Of course we need to own this business
because we're proud of it and we're part
of it.
So this whole thing kind of connects all
the dots.
And that's why we talk about dream
people culture all the time because
that's what,
in our experience,
merging with other companies,
that was the only thing that
differentiated performance wise,
our company from other companies.